mais d'abord une vague peut en cacher
une autre voici maintenant celle des
dépression l'anxiété liée au virus et au
second confinement à altérer notre moral
et ça se vérifie dans les chiffres le
nombre de personnes dépressives a doublé
depuis l'automne selon une étude de
santé publique france à tours nord le
centre médico-psychologique enregistre
chaque jour de nouvelles demandes de
soins
le reportage de samuel colin elles ont
en charge une cinquantaine de patients
chacune une large partie de leur travail
consiste à leur rendre visite pour
s'assurer de leur prise de médicaments
et plus largement de leur état de santé
ce second confinement est moins bien
vécue que le premier certains sont
beaucoup plus angoissés ont peur en fait
de vivre comme ça tout le temps que ça
va continuer comme ça c'est un peu plus
compliqué plus compliquée qu'au
printemps dernier où la situation alors
inédite est mieux acceptée et les
symptômes pour certains patients ou
justement ils n'ont pas le courage de
faire les choses donc le fait qu'on ait
chez eux
finalement pour eux cette est tout bénef
c'était pas compliqué au contraire voilà
on faisait pour eux donc c'était pas mal
après à la fin du premier conflit noah
il a fallu qu'on fasse machine arrière
fond redemande aux patients de faire
l'effort de revenir mais cette fois les
causes de stress ne manquent pas
l'incertitude l'impossibilité de se
projeter
l'absence de perspective les profils à
risque sont connus ici soignants
étudiants personnes isolées ou encore à
antécédents mais depuis le second
confinement les demandes de consultation
ne s'y limitent plus on a eu
effectivement un grand nombre de
nouvelles demandes
en lien avec des personnes qui jusque là
n'était pas suivi vous n'avez pas une
même d'antécédents psychiatriques donc
là effectivement il ya eu un grand
nombre de nouvelles demandes
pour ce type de ce profil ou manière de
passion mais dans ses premières demandes
de rendez vous une bonne part son duo
violence familiale ce qui explique qu'il
y ait plus de femmes que d'hommes à être
suivis en ce moment